that was really good
who starts Genie does
you
we are rolling
sound is speeding
we have a mark
action
you're not leaving
have to go
this is ridiculous you you sneak in here
unannounced you drink all of my wine you
[ __ ] me you leave me high and dry then
you go to the bathroom for like half an
hour and then you saunter off through
the dark and you start getting dressed
as if I wouldn't notice and without any
explanation it's pretty obvious that you
go to your [ __ ] dinner party okay
come on don't get angry I told you I was
going to the dinner party last week I
reminded you about the dinner party when
I arrived this afternoon
a couple hours ago you didn't seem to
mind you were very welcoming
I know but I
I changed my mind okay I changed my mind
I mean especially since it's
hours together in bed I mean normally we
have supper together and we cuddle and I
just
I just saw I thought we were gonna do
that tonight Shane I thought we were
gonna do that
okay well look
don't it's fine
don't make yourself feel guilty about
anything or anything like that okay I'm
not mad
just look it doesn't matter Michelle it
doesn't it doesn't matter nothing
matters okay it does matter it matters
to me I mean it's pretty obvious
obvious that you can't be with me
because there's another woman
okay
so what does that prove
I think you're a bastard for using me I
haven't used you oh I haven't used you
yes you have and I think Dave Hartley's
a bastard too for not inviting me to
that stupid [ __ ] dinner party too
okay well he's not putting it on Allison
Ridley is and she doesn't know you she
doesn't know about our relationship
we both decided that we'd have Separate
Lives separate friends and we wouldn't
become that perfect twosome okay our
relationship has never had any strings
because of you if I recall correctly
yeah well I
I changed my mind okay I changed my mind
Shane okay
look
I love you Shane and I just I I I want
to go with you tonight and can I can I
please just no you can't
not this late of hour it's a seated
dinner party okay so stop trying to make
me feel guilty
of course of course I'm not involved in
your inner little circle and it makes me
want to puke all of you the heart leaves
the oh hairs the O'Neills all of them
make me want to [ __ ] puke
you're so pretentious in your own little
[ __ ] Circle never allowing any
Outsiders ever
you with your old money you know you're
never allowing anybody but you guys you
know I think it is I think it's
incestuous all you do is hang out with
your country club people and your
Beverly Hills mansions and you never
allow anyone from the outside it's sick
I have to go I'm very late
you know I'm really sorry that this uh
had it ended on a bad note
but there's nothing else to be said so
I really wish we could have been friends
though
friends
hey your goddamn mind friends
why don't you go with that [ __ ] right
oh is she Debbie taunt part of like a
country club is that why you don't bring
around I bet you've got that dinner
you know there's one thing I don't
understand every single time you come
crawling back to me all hot and bothered
and I accept you for what
what is it because she's so pure and
virginial that you you can't you can't
you can't mess with her because you're
saving her for marriage and I'm just the
one that you [ __ ] with or is it because
she's not falling for your charms is
that it
great
I'm sorry I am
I I didn't mean to speak out a term
I didn't mean to be cruel I just um
just really hoping that we
could talk
I mean you know I love you
I've loved you since the first time I
saw you
I didn't mean any of it
I just I I treasure every moment that we
have together and I
I just thought
bye
very cut
that's a ton of dialogue girl yeah
that's all right nobody knows but you
and me we couldn't tell yeah nobody
knows nobody knows here's the thing to
remember once you're in motion you don't
stop
only the director says cut
or the DP they're the only people that
say cut actors don't cut a scene you
know
even William H Macy doing his eighth or
ninth season of Reckless
you know in the middle of a very
dramatic scene he went up on his lines
and he stopped he kept his attention and
focus on his partner because we know the
key to this whole thing is if you're
doing it correctly total concentration
of attention away from yourself is a
creative source of acting he stopped
kept his concentration said line please
and he gave him the line he backed up
two lines and picked it up and they
keep going
keep going the script coordinator will
make a note the director will make a
note they'll do a pickup shot don't you
worry that's not your you don't worry
about that that's not your job
does their job don't try to take church
out to be mad
you know you do your job
okay so nobody knows if you drop a line
trust me I know
you know maybe your partner knows
sometimes
but not always
getting more comfortable yeah I know it
you're yeah
okay are we ready
everybody's simmered ready in the booth
[Music]
at least those
on the animal
we are rolling
sound is speeding we have a mark
whenever you're ready
you're not leaving I have to go
so you come here unannounced you drink
all my wine you [ __ ] me you leave me
high and dry and then you're just out of
here you go to the bathroom for about
half an hour and then you come out you
change in the dark expect me not to say
anything not even to notice it's pretty
obvious you go in your [ __ ] dinner
party right now okay don't be mad I told
you about the dinner party last week I
reminded you about the dinner party
today when I arrived a couple hours ago
you did not care you were very welcoming
yeah but now I do care okay because it's
your last night in LA and I expect that
we be together especially after we spent
several hours together in bed
I mean normally you give me supper and
and we cuddle in bed for a while okay I
mean
like I am
Shane
I'm sorry I am
I I didn't want your last moments here
to beat the whole
I just I I love you
I'm sorry I didn't mean to make you make
it I'm not mad okay
and there's nothing to be sorry for
so stop trying to make yourself feel
guilty okay it doesn't matter Michelle
it doesn't matter
you know I think it does [ __ ] matter
especially after this evening I think
it's pretty clear that the reason why
you don't want to be with me is because
there's somebody else
okay
and that proves what completely your
[ __ ] [ __ ] need me that you've been
using me this whole time I'm not using
you you cannot use me you're using me
just like Dan Hardy I think he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] because he's invite me
to the dinner party okay well he's not
holding it Allison Ridley is and she
doesn't know you she doesn't know about
her relationship because we both decided
to keep everything everything separate
Our lives our friends we didn't become
that perfect twosome
our relationship has never had any
strings because of you if I recall
correctly
and besides you never liked my friends
until today so
because it changed my mind
it's very nice it's your last night here
I
and I just come with you to the dinner
party please no you can't you know you
know that not this late of an hour it's
a seated dinner party
so stop trying to make me feel guilty
wow didn't your precious little circle I
know all of you guys make me want to
vomit
you the parties
are all villains you and your your
precious little Elite Circle
never involving anyone else but
yourselves you're just a bunch of Rich
snobs that's what you are all the money
so hateful of everybody else but your
own selves you think you're incestuous
just hanging out at your Beverly Hills
mansions and your country clubs never
allowing any Outsiders it's sick it's
disgusting yeah I have to go it's late
okay I'm
I'm sorry this ended on a bad note but
there's nothing left to be said
and I I really wish we could have been
friends but friends
friends
get out of here
leave
go with your [ __ ] girlfriend I know
she's at that dinner party go with her
was she some debutante from some country
club some rich little family is that why
you don't want to bring her around
there's one thing I don't get why night
after night I'm the one you come
crawling back to
is it because she's too precious to be
deflowered
she's a virgin
you don't want to ruin her before
marriage
is it because you just bumped your
[ __ ] games
it doesn't fall for your charm
and your fancy clothes
maybe she's more Rich than she there
I'm sorry
that was um
cool
I am
I love you
I don't know I really want to spend your
last night together
if you want me
I didn't mean to be cruel you know I
just the first time I saw you I
knew that you were the one for me
foreign
give that girl a Prozac
yeah good good good good good good work
yeah all right bipolar
bipolar plus uh okay Rochelle and Mr
Abner